こんにちはこんにちははじめ社長ですさあ
皆さんここ二3億円のお家のキッチン作っ
た人がの木すると3000万円くらい
かかると言われているこのキッチンで今日
は動画を撮って行きたいと思いますみな
さんは高級な王子のキッチンでどういうの
を想像しますねもちろんこういうなんか
カウンター型のキッチンこっちでファイル
長にして立ってお客さんにキャス見たいな
とこういうなんかこういうの
それじゃ何も詳しくないんですけどこう
いうようなキッチンてだいたい変わってる
んですけどもここをまさに高級きっちその
もので誰が想像するでしょうかこれ冷凍庫
なんですよ備え月の凹部こんなに広くて
どうするんだこれ隠す必要があるのか様々
なおしゃれ用とか汁ばめられているこの子
q キッチンなんですけども私ふと思い
ましたがお金をつのいいとかな高級ホテル
とかって床がガラスばりになっていること
あると思うんですよで家のキッチンみて
くださいゆ活に石畳になってるんですけど
もこれだけ高級な3000万円のキッチン
だと床がガラスばになって言っても何ら
問題ないかなと思いまして今回ですね今
からこの言うとガラス貼りの床に交換して
もらうんですけれども
今日の動画ガラス板になった床が1枚だけ
はれるようになってるドッケンやっていた
ダメ
どういうことを説明しましょう今からこの
キッチンの床をガラス貼りの床に変えて
もらいますもちろん管理人の大地くんだっ
たり僕とが普段お家によく出入りする人は
その不自然さに気付くん松でーすがこの家
のことあんまりしてないとがここにきて
このチッチの床がが発売になっていても
あんなにわかんないと思うならちょっと
改造しましたと言ってもおかしくない
くらいからつまり向かってからさんです
けど丈夫な誰でも大丈夫なんですけども
今回特殊仕様で+バレないかな一番良い
だけはれてもいいから巣に交換してもらっ
てますもちろん安全なので安心して
くださいそこでターゲットかすごい取ら
れればダーってことあるイクって自分を
青地墜落するドッキリやっていきたいと
おもいます
歳でですね僕というわけでまずはセッティ
[音楽]
me
入っというわけできっついの準備が完了し
ましたご覧くださいまるで
お子からこうだったかのような高級感が
あふれる
ガラスが抜いたそもそもこの木全体
3000万円れすぐ助けて全然か遊ばれて
も何な問題なんだから盛りが正しいぐらい
のようなデザインにを刺し込ませて
いただきましたさあ何万音が割れてか
わかりますでしょうか手前のこれかこれが
これかこれかこれがた俺
島返還で追われますよやり察する感じに
乗ったにつくに仕掛けていきたいとおもい
ます
ライザー
はいよくん
あのキッズにトータル3000万円くらい
するぞ
作らは確かの海外製つくタイプ
外に改善させていただきましてもっと空
急患がソコンってを追う
若干高いみたいになる水道までもアンガー
確かにダサい
なるですん
くださいを
ファンのお客さんも
ご覧ください
でガラスばりさせていただきましたもう
これそれがおよそ言い切ってるからつまり
なく明日のオシャレ
涼風よねっこうでしょ
なんか冗談ねそんな米入ってください一方
コイニーハイこんなに聡明の英文ず綺麗な
出し方しかしたからねそうです
もうそれ
ない hey
別の例どうぞお願いん
踊り手ものだけど
はぁ
carああああああ
2ゲー
あんまして俺うわぁ
凄いセヨンイヤーって言ったそうですが
これウ
ということでガラス貼りの床が突き抜ける
ドッキリでしたよ
クサーってわかんないが船でまずちょっと
いない時にしてるかなと思ったけど全然
全然なんかあれこれどうすんだろうだった
花のアート政党ね
おつかれさまでした動けている
[音楽]
おったねぇ
1回で生
音を0秒決定
i am
それか改造を作ったまっせ
見てくださいこの
ずぅーっ護衛が下がりでなんかバック
ライトの光
えっなにひどい汚れをへ
た国政選挙にとかで普通に動いて総理と出
てるから前方が多くん
全ございますそれじゃ
ええええええ
rar
[音楽]
せいだろわー
入っていうで3人目次はこの3人の中で
最もアホですなんなら元々はアレだったん
じゃないかぐらいも感じてくると思うので
スピード残してみたいと思います入ってる
と思うんだよ
信じるよ
[音楽]
は
山らー
上着ってさぁ
髪型を頃思いなさったいっておいていると
かなんとですねあいつの代のころというか
開封しました解説なんというか面白い
あれどんな感じちょっとすごいよ見てみ
うわぁずらせばりましていただきました
横すごい所です
ね聡明だと思った
大丈夫なんかについてい
すごい道格ゲーめちゃコレです
元つまりされ
発動所を
したいところ骨盤でご用意さあ
[音楽]
ん
early
をしていた
恐れてるこれこれ
うわあああ
ああああああああ
ああああああ
toraman
[音楽]
うわぁ a 1
oo だったアーサー次のターゲットは
傭兵先生ですなかなか彼もこの3型のうち
にあんまり聞いたことないと思うんです
けどもなんとなくキッズらは分かっている
と思うのでなんとなキュート進みたいと
思います
いやー
goo
という方です繰り返すちょっと
サービング膣ハイローさんでぜひ見て
もらいたいなと思って
大丈夫
まず第一
コーン回の放送になる
今回はを得られるからね
なんかクッキーて3000万する
ライザー使うのガラスばりさせていただき
ましたね
フェのティーザーをどうぞ
この体さが入ってねー
ポンッ
いや混ぜ大丈夫かえらいまでないもう
ほとんどない
ダボん
car
tan
はぁ
はぁana
バンダー略称だよ
あっ
[音楽]
はい
bl